But while I may be the first woman in this office,...
...I will not be the last,...
...because every little girl watching tonight...
...sees that this is a country of possibilities.
And to the children of our country, regardless of your gender,...
...our country has sent you a clear message:...
...Dream with ambition, lead with conviction,...
...and see yourselves in a way that others may not,...
...simply because they've never seen it before,...
...but know that we will applaud you every step of the way.
And to the American people: No matter who you voted for,...
...I will strive to be a vice president like Joe was to President Obama,...
...loyal, honest and prepared,...
...waking up every day, thinking of you and your family.